le jour où mon concours au niveau d'un
jour je vais vérifier sur les réseaux si
nous sommes effectivement 120,0 les îles
mais qui est normalement venir des
jeunes sur twitter et sur facebook c'est
incroyable mais partout voilà la
technologie 1
c'est trop bien qu'on ait atteint les
5000 euros oui j'y crois ou pas on en
parlait
nous avons deux personnes qui nous
regardent actuellement à la du courbet
double en parler ces personnes sont sur
youtube ce qui est pratique puisque du
coup nous auront leurs commentaires mais
ce qui me semble qu'on n'a pas suivi et
reach sur le site facebook qu'on n'a pas
tout perdu et je reconnais bonjour
beaucoup aux spectateurs c'est un tous
les samedis c'est ce qu'ont fait un
petit village en plus ça sera un derby
samedi de la campagne bull est le doj
est tombé gens pensent qu'on lui dit et
on peut aussi ne pas entendre ce qu'on
peut dire avoir tourné la série en soi
c'est pas une mauvaise chose
c'est vrai rien je ne le ferai pas
génial quand votre première et en
deuxième c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on souhaite un
dossier kelly a fini avec ces pactes
belle est en train d'écrire le fiso 1
donc on devrait pouvoir tourner en 2028
façon la série est déjà écrite par
évidemment si c'était une blague
en fait c'est moi qu'on défile mais non
il faut pas dire ça il faut dire en fait
que l'on attend les machines d'ailleurs
j'ai lu le script fini fini il ya trois
jours
jamais pris le temps de le lire
j'avais lu les les versions je pense
juste un moment peut-être été arrêtée à
sept ou huit rames en plus en fait
j'avais pas eu le dernier car je pense à
la résolution du tout je les lieux
ah j'ai eu les larmes
pour de vrai c'était voilà je le dis à
une assise plus quand on l'aura tourner
plus avec la musique de où ça va être
bien évidemment en rien attendre cet été
les lieux on a valablement quel but lui
je voulais le tournage on va pouvoir se
nourrir des faits les déplacements des
gens puisqu'il ya une partie des titres
qui vient de 1 min ou reine de belgique
elissa de suite mais ben williams le
personnage qui est je n'ai pas prévoir
il ya six ans on aura même compositeur
que pour la saison de briques tout à
fait qui est un ami et va pouvoir
reprendre et qui nous montre le thème
des méchants il est incroyable j'avais
fait que l'envoi libéral en économie
c'est ça la fait en lamé vélo parce que
possible et c'est très peu est-ce qu'on
peut écrire nous dans le chat non on n'a
pas le droit
il connaît en bas à droite il ya un
bouton on en attend vous n'avez pas la
petite fenêtre à droite moi je viens
d'écrire - jeux de mots là bas en fait
j'ai la petite fenêtre mais je vois pas
où je dois être content si moi je peux
aussi un attend un wpt
ah oui non non effectivement non mais je
prends à l'entendre elle écrit pour
qu'on pour que les gens puissent
retrouver son travail plus nettement de
faire ça je voulais je voulais faire la
secrétaire du stream c'est vrai que
musique sont à tomber
ouais ouais il faisait très bonne
musique ces lieux si oui c'est lui qui
avait fait la musique de the north
sports ce bon premier court métrage
parodie de saint trop bien où elle a
évidemment il fallait quelque chose qui
ressemble à savoir mais avec mes parents
de la musique de savoir parce que sinon
ça et la très forte et puis quand même à
passer à 1
c'est donc ça et oui et à l'énorme
manque de gens de sabre laser dans
l'équipe
dans un autre registre qui est un peu
notre corps et de combat qui évidemment
est un pote pour la faire mais je pense
à toi à moi d'être avec vous mais
broadsheet en toi tu as regardé on
revenir à la saison ils auront dans le
budget pour défrayer ses paliers les
paliers d'après voilà le palier ce qui
est de 6000 euros vous permettra de
retrouver la condition que la saison us
ça coince entre 8h et accessoires dans
la revue technique
en plus de tout ça on avait eu
vraiment plus et dont 6 0 c'est ce qui
nous permettrait de versailles du coup à
5000 euros l'équipe b devant l'argentine
sera la fin de partie d'entre nous
évidemment un budget et dans six jours
contre la campagne se terminera le
refaire des calculs plus précis à partir
du nombre de consultants par exemple
voir exactement le coût des futures
parties clair pour l'instant si on a eu
des propositions il ya un jour de
tournage en gros la faire ailleurs des
petits calculs pour pouvoir faire et on
va pouvoir commander les accessoires
commencé à peindre reçu en tout cas pour
l'instant tout était bon à trouver et
donc voilà ça c'est le deuxième palier à
6000 euros donc comme il reste six jours
on peut espérer qu'on atteindra dans
tout cas qu'on saura qu israël est tout
tout tout noms supplémentaires mais
permettra de nous rapprocher les tout
argent sera utilisé des talents board
projets comme la pince y est reste à cet
article loin de tout le monde voilà
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire non plus sur
moi cette saison 2 j'ai faits liés aux
étapes je parlé un petit peu de détails
de la saison 200 transpolaires vaut
peut-être devenir un peu d un petit peu
plus de choses que la saison tube
milliards us sont restés sur la mémoire
parce que le système archives peut rien
et où
et du coup bah c'est pas sur la saison 2
comparé plus tu auras le le revisionner
révisionnisme historique c'est à dire
des gens qui essayent de belles
histoires à leurs sources pour je crois
que le titre politique est donc là on a
des personnages les champs qui change
selon des gens qui est celle d'un acteur
de l'histoire dans un but politique et
ses méchants may and culture aussi elle
a posé de problème
un peu à tout le monde à la propre assez
opaque au nrj aussi à la cité ce soir ça
va être intéressant vous bordel un beau
bordel mais précise le de résoudre pour
résumer ce sera la tagline est assez
beau bordel non mais ça à quelqu'un qui
dit les gens veulent plus de lettres
d'aliénor que de lucrecia et les
antidépresseurs peut être une citation
latine
elles mêmes est passable minorités de
chrétiens à bagdad a bien besoin des
sacs à main s'il est de la trempe on
apprécia mais non le trafic est aussi
elle a eu beaucoup de gens compris c'est
peut-être partie là c'est donc j'ai eu
l'idée
[Musique]
athenes un palier intermédiaire clinique
c'est un nouveau palier qui a été
rajouté et en gros en plus des contre
parties précédentes
les gens qui ont créé cette contrepartie
leur seconde lettre personnalisée de
remerciement manuscrite soin d'aller
larissa voulu préserver
voilà c'est mon choix dans un dossier
la scène du crime tu veux si tu veux
leurs écrits on peut aussi
moi je veux bien d'ailleurs je vous
pensais justement que notre version
augmentée de la saison d'une totale et
moi on n'a jamais diffusé ailleurs que
sur les dvd et les personnes qui avec
laquelle son parti dvd ont reçu parce
qu'elle commence à la fois qu'on a des
questions à temps vous avez fait de
commencer à établir un agenda de
tournage mais là j'en ai trop où on va
trouver sur six jours plus une journée
on doit partager les qui sera très forte
dans un autre lieu que c'est pour aller
filmer une personne fait un caméo ils
ont pu revoir tous déplacés chez elle
mais qui très vite parler de mon du
principe que tu te confinement à ce
moment là mais oui aussi appelé
compliments et si tout va bien qu'on
sera testé aussi alentours à se réunir
en un seul lieu notre normalité
après un constat met donc voilà sauf
aléa beloved on fonce sur six jours fin
juillet début août dans l'est de la
france et donc contrairement à la saison
ils ont été sur plusieurs week end là on
va tous se rassembler et qui tournait
d'affilée ça va revendre évidemment mais
ça va être plus simple et les registres
où ça est rien l avoir l'énergie la
synergie du vraiment être dans un état
d'esprit de tournage pendant une semaine
de trop collant gens motivés
parmi les rouen la nouvelle street par
exemple cliniques comme tu joues
laetitia tu dois écrire d'être bon mais
c'est laisser quelqu'un qui a pris la
laddh d'aliénor donc c'est quelqu'un qui
est d'ailleurs hélène dijk ce n'est pas
obligé de choisir tu peux refaire une
contrepartie à 60 euros et tu prends la
lettre et le critias comme ça tu as les
hommes de tête en contrepartie mai mais
ça il faudra mettre manuellement que tu
veux de l'être à mon avis quoi tu peux
nous écrire
il ya un jour l'histoire qui demandent
toujours six épisodes où vous n'allez
pas faire dix et bien si on va perdre 10
épisodes
c'est pour ça aussi que le budget est
conséquent puisque évidemment il ya plus
de plus de l'épisode plus de 30 ans a
rejoint toulouse dont ils espèrent tous
beaucoup plus de personnages qui vont
apparaître
donc voilà tout ça c'est ça qui me gêne
mais oui on a dix épisodes un peu plus
long ça a évidemment envie revoir monde
arabe mais à priori ils sont plus loin
surtout les derniers ne boivent jamais
le bas des commentaires nous sommes
toujours attendre jeu c'est agaçant mais
j'ai une petite quelqu'un qui dit
bonjour bonjour vincent roche bonjour et
là du coup pareil je vois pas le dans
les commentaires de l'argent d'histoire
parce que j'ai une popup à chacun que
maman
moi je peux pas voir les commentaires tu
peux je peux pas remonter j'en tire un
commentaire par ailleurs on se disait
qu'on pouvait tester à temps on peut
voir à chaque ici normalement quand vous
êtes mon message s'afficheront ma
pression c'est bien fichu et andré
cognet avancée mais en face à chaque
vague on veut toujours plus et je compte
aller vers l'autre aile mais c'est vrai
qu'on croyait bon on peut faire ça peut
faire ça on peut vous faire vous allez
on a bien nouveaux fonds ça fait
marquant en date deux titres on a le
lien bull est en dessous on elle fait
5000 au venin fois il fait alterner
entre orlando et c'est génial on va y
aller pour des gens à ne pas le lien il
est cliquable pour les gens ou pas non
pas qu'on pense que si lisse le stream
est en pause
il est dans mes outre il est dans mes
liens proposer automatiquement sur ma
page d'accueil des points au tordeur
cherche un chocolat puis le temps voilà
je te le dis je pour cause qu'on avait
suggéré l'idée à la barre avoir de prise
mais cette fois jamas que j'ai pas le
temps préparé la nouvelle question si
vous voulez de poser des questions
histoire de science-fiction kg si on
peut mais l'idée qu'on avait c'était
éventuellement si ça les intéresse tous
deux lancé le bêtisier les la saison
qu'une élégante malgré un ensemble voilà
c'est dit sac ouvert sympathique et bien
sûr on continue répond aux questions sur
la saison 2
aussi enfin son destin et 51,6 de le
retrouver sain est ce qu'on parle là
dessus ça me dit aussi commenté du corps
à wigan ou du coude j'imagine que oui et
oui commentait commenter si ça vous dit
dès 10 heures les spectateurs un objet
de l'eau j'ai dit cela sur le ton de la
blague a dit les égos utiliser deux
tasses les malus en qui tu as je sais
pas si vous allez voir les magnifiques
test de garage de l'offre est à l'envers
attendus pour cette fois dans son sac
pratique une passe donc à se rendre à
damas avant de lancer la vidéo je crois
qu'il me falloir faire quelque chose
oui à temps mais attends je vois un truc
je viens de voir les commentaires ça me
perturbe qu'est ce qui perturbe pas ce
que veut dire qu'on a eu
oui c'est un battant il ya même des cas
temps oui si c'est vraiment joli symbole
abh là il a vraiment pris les deux
lettres et de la colonne est il doit va
merci beaucoup je pense que c'est
défendable gaga merci beaucoup c'est
trop gentil je dois écrire est un petit
bonjour bravo et merci d'un compagnon et
leurs draps et mma on atteint
aujourd'hui les 5000 euros pour le
premier et pour le financement de la
saison 2 donc on va pouvoir la tournée
on est enfin c'est le premier panier
qu'on avait défini donc là c'est bon on
peut la tournée comme il nous reste six
jours on espère atteindre
deuxième qui nous permettra d'améliorer
les choses on sait encore ça parlait
encore faisable dans ce cas tout don
supplémentaire pourra toujours nous
aider et sera entièrement investis dans
le projet mais au moins la map ans
assureront le tourner la seconde c'est
viable tourné à chambord noir projet
réel
on a des beaux lieux on a des
magnifiques café du nord
on a fait revoter nord j'ai des raisons
du nord c'est d'abord chanté l'hymne de
renaissance nom aussi ah oui il ya le
centre le centre des maisons du centre y
aurait un petit peu de la région centre
une petite vous donne une idée du quai
mais dans laquelle seront tournés trois
plans littéralement et l'autre et les
collines du nord puisque maintenant on
est pas si plat on va tourner et on a
repéré un arbre qu'on a fait des
repérages pour l'argentine qui ne vous
est pas ce qu un arbre avec un armement
j'ai alors vraiment j'avais prévu jusque
là ménagé par référence et donc voilà
pour les deux tournages on a offert une
belle maison à un arva ça peut vous
donner quelques indices d re aussi les
rues il faut que tout en confirmant une
piscine officiers 5000 euros de l'argent
pour prouver la piscine pour notre lieu
de tournage pour le lion sera basé
pendant le tournage pourra creuser la
piscine pour se détendre le soir et ça
c'est grâce à lui je pense que ce n'est
pas la qualité n'est pas là et que
l'accès des listes déjà c'est pas mal en
pis si on n'avait pas d'enfant parce que
quand même qui est visible
autant la junte et les bons pour
l'instant les partis ni qui ni à sa
piscine mais disons qu'elle est en cours
ou tuer je pense que d'ici cet été
laurent médoc où ça rend bien sur les
planches rouge dans la fiole quand tu
vois de la bullshit face à ce que je
vous dis oui propose de l'ancien patro
le tournage ou et en prendra plein
julier des villes hôtes sur six jours
donc le toutou d'affilée le concept
voilà la saison ce week end
donc on à l'abordage non sauf comics et
s'affale le seul aléa bonjour laisse
partir toutes moins chez nous et notre
résistance nous faire un coucou
bonjour les régisseurs d'un coup par de
nourrir les repérages à tous les
repérages foncé j'ai pu les faire avant
confinement c'était bien et donc les
derniers jo a été validée la consigne
est notamment une ferme locale et des
disponibilités des propriétaires leur
accord à des talents j'ai visité
plusieurs endroits et ils sont partants
on me trouvais ça pour dire que le
consentement c'est important quand on
fait le show
c'est vrai que ça fait penser à tv5 chez
les gens et les analystes y est alors
monté league echl et à deux expériences
le d'autres des gens qui déjeunent mais
qu'est ce que vous faites là qu'il vous
est pour bientôt chez moi pour me
demander ma campagne dans le nord qui
n'a pas été dans l'estomac des montagnes
dans l'est aussi l'heure de jeu de
l'équipe
l'archiduc banque de belgique c'est
entre les deux ponts entre les gens
viennent de paris l'ancien de neige et
on sera notamment pour accoucher à ça et
tourner le réseau le réseau proche
le secret pour faire ce qu'on croit dans
l'est ou en voyage
évidemment j'ai déjà des projets pour la
saison
chaque chose en son temps bretagne alors
c'est compliqué de quoi la bretagne à la
mamelle commentaire non c'est juste et
qu'emmi qui disait ah oui et chacun
chaque chaque personne va proposer sa
région c'est sous la halle à lausanne
c'est vachement bien la lozère c'est
hyper beau c'est le plus bel endroit du
monde j'en reviens pas voilà je vais
aller en touraine ça ressemble à quoi
villa ancienne maison grandi c'est bien
aussi
ouais la normandie avec un truc on part
sur un tir d'essai de l'agent finalement
il ya des châteaux en touraine
il ya beaucoup de travail mais du coup
ça a du sens à jean macé bourse et bow
wow non c'est beau effectivement ça va
ça se défend
non mais je ne savais pas où c'était
vraiment parce que je suis une bo l'as
tu as eu la crau lucia ce coup je suis
déjà allé en touraine d'abord les ont
tout ça non j'étais trop ça alors il
pourrait ne sais pas je ne suis pas un
terme qui est très utilisé je trouve les
gens disent plutôt les villes clés que
les régions dans ce coin là j'ai
l'impression
ben moi comme on à l'histoire se
retrouvent leur chemin qui défend créé
des jeux s'est passé en valais c'est à
dire c'est chez moi [ __ ] quand j'étais
passé j'ai pas vraiment imaginer time
warp lamente n'emballerait le parisienne
la saison mais on la veut tourner la
page et je peux aussi par ce site
sportif puisque il ya une semaine et
spots de photos quoi j'ai passé deux
jours à très faible attrait julien
désolé les gars qui habitent les
chrétiens wall e créteil est je crois
que j'ai déjà pu mener à créteil pas les
chauffer ce qu'on a dit il ya des
châteaux à peu près partout je ne pense
pas trop proche de paris pour élargir
je pense que c'est utilisé de manière
plus générale oui je vais tenter de
lancer le v6 est une poignée de sa
volaille est placé depuis le local donc
à la journée le live sur mon tel comme
ça je vais voir en même temps moi c'est
trop beau le nom le gentil qu'il y ait
de créteil c'est trop beau les
cristoliens c'est trop stylé alors alors
je vais tenter à mon avis ça doit
vraiment laggé que si on passait par le
recul sans local dont on va voir on
choisit une vidéo
ah oui à tangente est d'abord passé
l'écran n'est pas dedans comme harry non
je crois que je pourrais le même temps
plein écran
moi je pense que là ça ne sert à rien et
en fait ouais non attends là on va y
arriver dans les flandres mais quelqu'un
qui demande dans quel point c'est dans
les flandres françaises stress est ce
qu'on a le son j'ai entendu qu'elle off
oui mais y'a plus notre sont à nous je
croix rouge et 6 est ce que vous
entendez la vidéo
normalement elles sont c'est vrai qu'il
verse est bon
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on entende le
bègue attend je mets 1 1
[Musique]
ainsi on assiste la bande de gaza en
laissant mais pas de la vidéo
[Musique]
dès lors on n'entend pas tout mais du
coup nous on n'a pas le sont ses
fonctions c'est pourquoi c'est pas ces
pratiques ainsi qu'elle anodiques tout
le monde et ils nous reçoivent bien il
nous entendra tout le monde c'est tout
est bon un mois maintenant mais pas dans
cette idée possible en principe parce
que non c'est parce que en train de se
dire à jean quand je mets les fleurons
japonais
oui c'est en flandre flandre intérieure
on tournera mais genre vous l'entendez
pas du tout la vidéo parce que moi je
l'entends un peu moins moi j'entends pas
du tout mais cette fois parce que c'est
moi qui ai l'argent fait ouais c'est
marrant c'est bizarre ça vous êtes les
plus forts qu'eux
[Rires]
bah là mais du coup c'est pas ça va être
pratique ce que le but c'est qu'on
aurait enfin que kate jane buteuse en
danger unique vous vous entendez bonjour
temps ok on va faire quelque chose à ce
titre là les souvenirs
ça fait très longtemps que j'avais pas
regardé bon on voit je pense depuis la
projection je vais pas regarder là on
n'avait même pas inscrits n'étaient pas
à huy la série le bêtisier laissez pas
encore dispo au moment de la projection
ouais voilà on est presque on a presque
trouvé le moment où vous êtes à peu près
à vous la mettez en même temps voilà
maintenant en a trop ah oui obtient
cette scène avec le rideau host et
l'enfer sur terre parce que derrière le
mur il ya vraiment un escalier très
sympa quoi on pouvait pas là bloqué
enfin en aucune manière on était obligé
de l'avoir dans le champ peu par rapport
aux trucs comme alienware étaient censés
rentrer dans la pièce il y avait que par
laquelle pouvait passer et du coup elles
étaient oubliées ont été obligés d'avoir
la fenêtre dans le champ
en contre-jour horrible ah c'était les
gars je pense va avoir hésité pas loin
de se casser la figure
c'était assez comique mais le plan a
fonctionné et on sent même pas content
si on ne sait pas quand on voit les
tâches à florence ne peut donc ces
passionnés moi j'avais florence demande
qu'à celles à ce groupe
dans ce coin là on sera autour de
godewaersvelde
voilà je pense que tu connais je pense
que dans les commentaires c'était où là
on est à paris
on est alors je sais pas les
arrondissements moi papa je sais plus
non plus dans paris qu une petite faute
à une peu tous les quartiers où les
cafetiers plus de résidents sied mal
d'ailleurs il y avait un déménagement
dans cette ruelle
enfin je crois c'était peut-être pas un
déménagement ou un merdier lui qui
voulait gens partaient toi en tout cas
il y avait des livres des puzzles seaway
c'était ça repart vraiment une autre
crash restent au heat qui revient pour
la saison 2 dans son propre rôle qui
retient aussi la gestion non sur une
partie oui 2 3 ah là là je me retrouve
au nombre de fois on a fait ses prix ce
cas avec les gpu alors faire la tournée
dans la pévèle
j'espère va quitter notre script mais il
pourra pas être là par contre sur la
saison qu'on dit de prendre vraiment un
choix
sauf qu'on ne se rende pas trop compte
que c'est vraiment la même c'est censé
être un peu dans un quartier animé comme
on n'avait qu'une rock et pascal te
cache en fait ben la robinsonnade et
régisseur sur ce qui s'est passé dans
l'île et les régisseurs à nous rejoindre
sur toute la saison peut-être à manger
tous les jours ont été tournées à
l'image des parts de marché la
différence dans l'appartement c'est fou
la vie et c'est bien comme cette
histoire
ouais on s'était en était pourtant
parfois improviser à ça c'était pas moi
à boire
c'est vrai les femmes investies dans le
groupe
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un pont à l'autre ce
n'était pas du tout de même temps un
enfer d'ailleurs je parle de suisse et
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas où il y avait
une source souhaitant payet sur cette
plante on n'a pas réussi à la case
énormément et là on a avoué on avait des
et voitures qu'on entendait chez moi je
me sens bien dans les villes que sur la
zone histoire physique qui passe juste
en vitesse pour dire bravo d'avoir un
premier palier merci beaucoup
j'aurais plaisir et oui rien c'est avec
ces plans ben je trouve que tu es drôle
[Rires]
très étroite
donc on était en retard sur le nom mais
ça veut dire en cause contraintes
beaucoup de plans à tourner un lieu j'ai
passé on avait pu faire des repérages la
veille mais c'était pas être assez
compliqué surtout qu'on ait pris mon sur
les gens on descendait dans laquelle du
coup ça les met la lumière et demi
salaire voire plus c'est le faire dit
qu'il fallait se dépêcher
on avait le bon sens à ces horaires avec
le pauvre pauvre thierry qui avait calé
son boulot en plus on était un faux
tributaire malheureusement dossier
le ceser de barman et il dormait trois
heures par nuit et les pilleurs de
tombes est vraiment gérer pour le 4 mai
et avaient beau 3 aussi un parcours que
justin on te voit on est en groupe
[Rires]
et à ma dépendance alcoolique et
abondance être la fameuse les biens bien
chaude bien je bien chaleureuse de
lumière non pas du tout dans l'ambiance
qu'on voulait faire je te trouve pas ça
joue annoncer le nom mais c'est de la
lumière jaune quoi c'est pas du tout
mais comment nous a dit trouver après
après une sortie draghi qui séparait moi
je dis on les rase tout ce qui dépasse
jusqu'à ce que je veux bien vous parlait
en fait je suis un peu d'oublier aussi
tout ce que vous venez de dire ça
m'arrangerait jeunes ils le sont très
bons je suis en train de juger en train
de montrer leurs tentes
[Rires]
c'est pas moi pour moi au galop alala
cette porte là pourquoi même pas là pour
aînés je ne sais pas comment c'est
possible ailleurs
de l'extérieur la poignée de
fonctionnaires mais quand tu l'acte
active la change à l'intérieur et on
bouge pas je n'ai jamais compris comment
elle fonctionnait sa porte
et oui c'est ouais moi je me rappelle
pas de cette histoire je me rappelle que
j'ai vu dans une tasse
je sais pas trop comment là aussi comme
c'était un grand coup droit avec moi
j'avais leur changement posthume
des fois ça c'était pas y avait vraiment
une pour le coup on avait vraiment une
régie dans une autre pièce je coupe mon
chien se met au milieu du couloir s'il
vous plaît avant ces fameux déplacement
dans le cube noir au coeur des banques
n'ont pas de projet mais attention ne
sais pas si guerre il ya eu un plan on
voyait comment le travelling avait été
fait
j'ai vu des photos mais je comprenais
que jamais bruno mettling ses amis d'un
making-of
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu le
meilleur français du tour
dans cette scène
on marche avec donc thierry et la prof
pour faire le travelling au jeu bt mise
sur une chaise de bureau que tyreke
bonne foi c'était assez de sport le
faisant il m'a tiré pendant ce cas de
crise
c'est bon et puis à la fin d'ailleurs il
a même failli à la grande punto suisse
au mois et et godefroy de hobbits sur
des courts ici les manger mais assez
mangé placée de bureaux de la sibérie
stoppée net [ __ ] je pense si vous
voulez quelque chose de très épuré pour
pas qu'on ait l'impression d'être dans
le futur puisque quand même des gens
d'autres aux époques dans ce bureau
les cyber historiens encore envie que
les gens du passé loi à quoi ressemble
un croisé donc ils ont entre la mare
aussi on devra pigeons des plantes et
des syndicats simplement jolies soir que
ça et qu'on ne voit pas la magie du
cadrage je me fatigue très épuisante
aussi ce nom j'ai plus compte de plus on
en avait on avait plus de 40 ou 50 plomb
je crois
sur la poupe la faille au service des
stages techniques sans suite abba et
concentre toi surtout que vous en avez
la cerda tente on avait la somme de
pouvoir et nabeul et on a eu plein de
trucs dufermont
on cherche à grossir la lumière et
sachant que bat pour le coup j'étais
tout seul
j'étais tout seul contre tous les
trafics illégaux est allé au commerce
donc enfin briller en mai lieu il ya au
moins moi qui les ai vus et apprendre y
en avait une contrainte de temps c'est
un petit doute aussi parce que - se
départir
qu'ont fait les comptes en photo il
fallait que thierry thierry je croyais
devait partir à 13h ou un travail à
cause de son décès ne marque pas aussi
attend la salle journée j'ai demandé et
c'est le besoin d'être vente sur ma
saison veut basse il ya tenu on va
partir aussi s
non je pense que les deux ans le verrez
plus jamais on va bien délégué pain et
des trucs à faire on va bien
c'était ça aussi qui était clair crevant
c'est que
on y avait très peu de postes et que du
coup enfin a déjà reparti bon quand on a
l'expérience aussi maintenant on sait
comment faire toi même si tu regardes
les mafias ça et que l'aspect technique
vincent
[Rires]
oui en fait c'est la faute à l'uci ne
rien n'est sûr mais non c'est pas
possible
ok on la double sert à mieux
ok allez essayer au maximum ne pas
bouger je sais que c'est compliqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour c'est moi et ça c'est vraiment
[Musique]
celui ci
j
[Musique]
techniquement simple des choses en moi
voilà quelle musique incroyable quelle
musique un père qui est mort j'utilise
dans la lumière deux vraiment cool
c'était ma wii mouais c'était super et
dans les king vous pouvez voir un psy
d'ailleurs comment valentin a composé la
musique
en face et qu'on a regardé sur youtube
homme est vraiment très technique non
nous rend pas c'est surtout vers la
nouvelle saison pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'effets spéciaux
il avait à temps là à temps à oui oui
effectivement oui a du coup c'est pas
ouais ouais bon voilà quoi de plus
symbolique est même déjà là en plus dans
la seine
mais fallu attendre plusieurs fois parce
que j'avais le mois a levé la force et
aliénor doué et puis ça bouge elle avait
tiré est avait tiré qui bougeait et tout
on avait les contraintes qu'on avait
plein de contraintes
florence je faisais et bah oui j'ai
essayé aussi de de pas avoir trop de
plans sur lesquels il ya plusieurs
personnages qu'on est dans la nasse
comédienne patience va pour moi je
continue de jouer la prof et aliénor
clélie joue toujours le christiane mais
aussi un nouveau personnage
d'autres vont faire attention à ça quand
on convoque des gros plans madère savez
tout le monde à poil et prend un verre
c'est compliqué ça et encore ans c'est
pareil elle joue toujours dans l
historienne de la pirate et elle a aussi
un 3-0 pour cette saison 2 donc
qu'est-ce qui est on
c'était un calcul aussi d'en comprendre
le scénario de dire à la fin c'est
vraiment ce personnage là qu'on veut qui
porte notre personnage par exemple parce
que je sais que c'est la même personne
on va pas faire ça voilà oui en fait
c'est vrai que ça passe krebs
enfin je m'en suis même pas rendu compte
que du coup parce que tu vois comme
comme le scénario extrême cerexhe du
coup ça passe crème ah ah ça va être ça
va être quand même un enfer à tourner je
pense aller mais les changements de
posture et la soeur on n'a pas encore
fait le découpage technique par jour
fallait donc et ça en fera on en tiendra
compte pour éviter ça ne se change pas
trois mais ça sera ça plus cher il y
aura pas trop de plans normalement je
sais que tu trouveras liste des effets
des effets spéciaux donc je peux dire
exactement quand il y en a mais il n'y
aura pas trop de plans surtout en plus
avec les changements de costumes autant
toit où ça va c'est facile en soit ce
que bon la prof aliénor genre t'as pas
de perruque
c'est quand même pour hâtivement simple
que là aucun défi c'est un peu plus
compliqué ouais on est d'ailleurs on
admet tout de suite que la croix fait
l'énorme à 100% que je ne vais pas
refaire de peinture mais bon c'est
soleil c'est 2021 nouveau grand nombre
de questions
ça a été au rendez vous pour les cm2
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà commencé à
on avait un avion s'est appelée avec
celui qui aura la cascade et j'ai envoyé
scénario est pour l'instant il a encore
fait des retours en même temps de le
lire de réfléchir mais il est motivé et
je pense qu'il pourra faire des choses
bien
je n'ai pas franchement l'ailé les
cascades ça sera des grosses grosses
scènes de combat de l'hindustan c'est le
bus et les quelques petites scènes
quelques coups sont échangés ne soient
crédibles y aura in répète d'ailleurs
bas il y aura de la tête pour même
douala parce que quand on sera tous sur
place est ce qu'il ya une vraie main que
prévu n'est pas un fait c'est un bon
gars disent il devra les gens que tu as
ces personnes à chalon les apprentis
mais ça sera des gens du nord
ah oui c'est entre tous les gens du nord
je vais réfléchir c'est une bonne
question
en bref le plus technique genre dans là
c'est la semaine où on est tous là genre
la veille de conleau moment enfin la
veille de la semaine de tournage je sais
pas si c'est faisable ou quoi qu'est-ce
qui se passe
non parce que si on répète pour les
cascades n'avait pas d'âge et en plus on
peut pas la mettre en valeur un fossé
jeudi bruxelles en petit ou alors ou
alors faudrait que la personne qui gère
les cascades
je sais pas s'il va répéter avec des
gens qui connaît et j'en serai qui filme
un peu le truc comme ça on voit déjà à
quoi ça ressemble tu vois ça ça peut
être une solution
oui comme ça au moins ça tu vois les
jeux et la limite les gens chacun de
leur côté peuvent un peu pas forcément
répéter mais un peu voir les mouvements
les trucs comme ça elle ne risque pas
pour l'abordage
le bcl ces deux jours sont importants et
si c'est ça il
euh oui ballon sert allait bien elle est
un sujet chaud j'ai compris qu'elle doit
elle est le second personnage
c'est là d'ailleurs
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire
voilà mon personnage c'est peu de le
dire mais qui est très drôle vraiment
c'est l'essai nous faisait vraiment
rigolé genre j'ai vu là c'est vraiment
le comique rue leaf mais c'est trop et
que sa williams cos plus tard ben ça
apporte un autre genre d'humour qui
avait un petit peu avec aliénor mais pas
tant pas tant que ça enfin du coup faut
que ça force le trait encore plus c'est
ça qui est cool c'est ce dont il ya
vraiment plusieurs types d'humour
différent il y en a un peu pour tout le
monde
peut-être peut-être n'en avons que dire
du coup il avait 3
pour le personnage est nécessaire de
famille mais je parle des concurrents
s'est pas senti cette question qu'à son
propre but aussi haute en couleurs
pourquoi tu dis ça on va trouver une
tenue ça y est non tu dis bonjour la
part de rouille et notre exemple a
estimé j'aime bien le 1 du coup enfin je
trouve que c'est sympa alors le spar et
son histoire
elle arrive quand saison nous donc du
coup c'est toujours un peu particulier
parce que les autres personnages on les
connaît tout ça mais je trouve que le
spice à tramayes
enfin sa trame de son intrigue et tous
et elle est agaçante à la fin et tout à
vous verrez bien et ses sources et maran
la thématique taha porte avec les autres
personnages avec qui elle a des
relations défaire des connexions un
intéressant c'est cool comme ça va être
sympa vous allez aimer
[Musique]
j'essaie de l'espionnage aussi les noirs
un peu développée en france il ya une
fille qui est aussi qui tient un peu
paumée au début et qui essayent qui
essayent de moi de prendre de trouver sa
place parmi les autres alors qu'elle
avait pas toujours très dégourdi et on
va les amoureux entend maintenant 90
merci lors gaillard
mme bayard oui merci beaucoup très
gentil j'achète nana qui a donné 100
euros je ne sais pas si c'est parce que
je ne vois pas en quoi aussi qu'il avait
donnée avant mais merci à toi et on peut
mettre à jour vous avez plutôt tendre
vers la caricature ou tenter d'être
proche de la véracité historique pour le
personnage declémy costumes attitude
pour le costume on va essayer de faire
quelque chose dans les budgets qu'on a
évidemment dont l'exceptionnel menace de
taille noir qui sont pas l'historique
internet avec jets qui permet de mettre
ça serait cool hein on va essayer
d'avoir quand même un beau costume ne
pas partir dans un truc trop raidie plus
en plus s'ils ont des tables si tu as
besoin des deux j'ai du temps oui mais
je voulais vous en parlait d'ailleurs
par exemple ça je le vois les rayons
travail à l'aimer tous les crimes
par exemple si tu veux faire quand on
postule ça elle est une des rares
je me sentis obligés dire oui maintenant
parce qu'on aurait conduit on en
reparlera mais c'est vrai que si on
pouvait mais des papillons la ceinture
ce pays est dans l'équipe et je sais pas
cette famille entend gagner qu'elle veut
donner 10 euros j'ai pas si c'est vrai
je ne mange pas je suis déjà à jour pour
les 5000 90 oui mais nous les avons
atteints à je n'ai pas vu qui avait
suivi qu'elle ait participé
messire elle a participé et jouer dans
twilight mon autre court métrage et il a
donné acte où récemment des ventes ou
bien vers le duc ou 22 cents
mais du coup c'est il faut avoir des
scènes sexy salon s'est amusé à faire
oui mais oui du coup pour les costumes
du coup comme enfin on est près du quai
de saint pierre et tout c'est plus
facile en plus pour avoir donné des
trucs un bon truc comme ça par confort
par des jets du temps je prendrai
et d'ailleurs je sais plus et ma soeur
qui pour l'un des costumes pour l'un des
costumes très axé très secondaire j'ai
baisé pourquoi dans le jet privé d'un
cerf prière pascale à la wii la wii et
puis là pour ça c'est pas grave s'il ci
n'est pas hyper il a sciemment ça veut
pas ça doit même pas attristé je vois
bien les trucs hyper caricaturaux deux
pas de ce qu'on peut voir sur internet
pour les personnes malgré tout ça il
faut pas qu'on tombe dans les trucs
racistes homophobes et youtube mais ça
peut être ça peut être drôle non
on va commencer l'enfer aulas et c'est
la chute
c'est la chute voilà bien casquette
pendant six ans après parce que si oui
il y aura un passage dans la saison 2
murat des gens d estime qu'ils seront
pas ici tout est donc là on va s'amuser
ça va être drôle mais un petit passage à
vide en enfer à tourner mais sympa pour
le coup j'avais tourné une une soirée
dont le thème était cpi ce taux est
vraiment c'est c'est assez cool en fait
enfin tu prends un peu de temps et
qu'elle était plan mais rendrait
excellence et à après faudrait nous
faudra peut-être quelqu'un un peu de
préposé pour le coc au figurant il y en
aura ce que ça peut être vite pas
gérable enfin ça fait un truc en plus à
gérer
un deuxième à this man ray à l'épicier
celui des figurants ça marche aussi
[Musique]
prendre est le chef de file est pas
censé s'occuper de mise en scène tu vois
venir les figurants et ofer robin n'aura
pas besoin d'être régis toujours là
puisque c'est pour l'heure une tranchée
naceur elle a décidé de figure merci d
luffy race pourtant que tapota
contrepartie qui nous a donné un petit
truc en plus ah oui merci
nous sommes à simple il s'en fout c'est
très gentil
qu'est-ce qu'on a me disais que le lieu
où on tournera les soirs et je le sais
il faudrait que vous envoie les photos
de tous les lieux d'ailleurs va toile où
tu en as déjà vu un petit peu mais cet
endroit là je pense que bayard un plan
que j'imagine qu'il est déjà trop mou 1
cl c'est chez ma soeur est et s'il fait
beau que tourner sur sa terrasse il ya
moyen de faire des choses très joli
style et à d'autres questions pour
l'instant oui le jeu pour revenir aux
personnes clemi par contre pour
l'attitude de l'aca sera opéré quatre
chemins quand même c'est un personnage
gros j'aime à dire des choses qui sera
aussi avec mouvement est bien trop
tarder aux classes de personnages ainsi
à un nouveau personnage s'appelle
william qui vient aussi d'une époque
antérieure qui est aussi un ancêtre ce
qu'on a ici des personnages qui ne sont
pas des ancêtres évidemment mais on va
pas tous foyers non plus on a par
exemple philippe d'accord exemple le tic
en toilettes
ça vient ça spoile pas du tout à ce
genre je sais pas pourquoi j'ai choisi
ce prénom c'était les militants de
gauche ah oui les essais des cocos ans
et est communiste d'un vraiment liban
toilettes le morphisme n'est pas mort
[Musique]
mais williams et ses relances être aussi
qui viendra d'une autre époque
bien qu est-ce qu il ya un budget pour
une connexion internet émis une nouvelle
contrepartie est vrai une nouvelle
contribution
voir et alors je sais pas si on va
pouvoir dire le pseudo et on va pas
pouvoir dire un pseudo
et on sait pas si on va pas faire ce que
tu dis non merci merci pour ton oui tous
les dons sont acceptés même ceux de nos
malades et nos options on les prend
quand même nous tu sais on est au choix
zip a enfin on est très peu regardants
tant que tant qu'ils patrouillent
d'extrême droite on prend et le caméo le
caméo
la cour a tourné dans la région touraine
tu peux je pense tu peux deviner c'est
relativement simple
voilà un camée et aux rapports avec la
chaîne de la prof année-là tourne autour
de tout temps fait la loi
la 8 me dont l'épave a tu sais il faut
que je joue du coup c'est la tour n est
pas pareil a parlé du belize et
bâtiments c'est le monde colonial ou
napoléonien non ça
enfin c'est la façon dont il avec les
finances oui c'est ça qui a pas grand
chose de cool le financement des
bâtiments historiques en france en ce
lundi
oui je m'emporte trucs depuis la mine
aussi têtus que je ne vous voit presque
plus on te voit
non messieurs je suis pas mon écran il
décide de mettre la luminosité au
minimum de fautes je vois presque à rien
tu toujours aller de l'avant si c'est
tout ce moment de la partie sombre de la
saison 2 les deux méchants
sinon on va pas trahi et déjà dit que
les champs ils sont vraiment très belles
chances qu'ils essayent de réécrire
l'histoire d'un méchant ça se fait pas
et peut donc ils viennent également
d'une époque futur et voilà et bon son
bien il ya quelques bons personnages je
pense avant cela oui est-ce qu'on a
conduit à la question sur l écriture des
épisodes où et à quelle était cette
question est ce que les acteurs
participe à l'écriture de la base de
leurs personnages super g j'ai réfléchi
si c'est pas du tout si parfois il ya
des suggestions sur les thèmes choisis
désuni choisir mon roman saison 1 mais
je crois que c'est tout et chez même pas
si on a gardé le bronze au togo ici on
l'a mais bon c'est moi qui faisais un
caprice quoi
ça a payé un concert d'ailleurs ma
pensée pour le nikkei avait oublié ce
haut lieu
je regarde mais attention à ne pas
financer son futur employeur amour avec
ce pseudo merci le niveau du combat en
fait on en croit ces éléments n'ont
échoué par de nouveaux acteurs wissous
de niro principalement des nouveaux
maîtres
[Musique]
vous avez déjà vu mais c'est mieux quand
il ya le chat dans la vidéo parce que si
des gens regardent en effet nous
ajusterons bientôt dix ans et c'est
drôle quand tu aurais dû en parler plus
si oui c'est le chemin
oui c'est pas si vous voulez une pince à
du dessin et peut être couleurs et s'il
ya des gens qui veulent et spontanée
scribble de garde faune déjà est ce
qu'il ya des gens dans le staff qui
volent éventuellement en revanche
d'énergie un petit script est lié au moi
j'avoue que je serais pas contre c'est
plus simple quand on est nombreux déjà
ouais parce que garde faune à 5 commence
tu peux dire
le dire à quelle époque entretien pas en
prison mais en fait ça aurait pu être
relou et puis je voulais pas que vous
ayez à dire en live ah non désolé c'est
relou est ce que tu peux faire deux
parties avec nous machin ce que j'aurais
fait si ç'avait été relooké par je sais
pas est ce que c'est relou hockey parce
que j'aime bien déménagement aujourd'hui
donc c'est mon excuse j'aurai une excuse
tous les soirs j'ai toujours fatigué je
suis une mamie mais voilà aujourd'hui on
excuse c'est le déménagement je vais
vous laisser jouer du coup c'était cool
vendors bien et on se revoit on aura six
à si c'était le dernier live on se
reverra vous aurez fait visio pour la
série et bonne soirée à toi je ferme tu
sais combien c'est ça mais je veux que
je peux te faire disparaître à tout
moment ce monsieur je sais tout de suite
moi j'ai tout la wii je fait effacer de
l'existence de un lancement une bonne
année on n'a pas toujours le bonheur que
nous on voit la bad boy on va partir sur
du dessin je te laisser partir sur votre
ordi des coups comme ça tu vas faire
paraître et aecom et donc voilà si des
gens veulent venir destinée avec nous
vous pouvez on va avoir les deux a
priori à ma soeur qui peut nous
rejoindre d'ailleurs aussi donc je lui
j'ai tout de suite créé le le le lien là
pour pouvoir l'envoyer à vous et à tout
le monde
si ça fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne
pas sur la tablette ça va être rigolo
c'est pas j'en ai en français de
préférence et coupez-les sont aussi ça
va être long mais temps sinon donc voilà
dans le chatt n'hésitez pas si vous
voulez ou alors si vous voulez venir
jouer vous pouvez peut-être se couper le
son de votre page scribble les traits
sombres peut-être aller mais la grande
lumière magescq rival qui tourne un
voyage et les pompiers la police
on va peut-être plus la police le
policier
[Musique]
je vous ai envoyé le lien ce tribunal
alors comment je vais faire moi du coup
je vais partager mon écran je pense
[Musique]
qu'au pied tic tic
on se fait ça il quitte demain petit
quart d'heure une petite demi heure oui
oui je pense pour terminer on commence à
la vous êtes sûr là je vois que moi
c'est normal je n'arrive je veux 18 ans
au devoir de réserve oblige à vous c'est
ici un petit c'est inaccessible entre ce
nouveau petit poucet le monde à ce
contenu
attends je me mets en tic tic tic la
couleur un petit verre normalement
on va enlever ce sont de merde parce que
ça va très vite
taper sur le système je dispose et qui
disent qu'on nous a donc bien son double
y aller et à temps mais je sais que je
vais je veux pas mettre la wii mais
attention ce que du coup sinon ça va
être l'enfer pour dessiner
[Musique]
bon va tenter alors tant pis ça peut
être l'enfer mais parce que du coup j'ai
pas de cépages et pas de jeu sur une
table est donc j'ai pas de clavier 1-1
pourquoi que les cours taper les trucs
enfin si du coup quand tu tape sur
l'écran ça ça fait apparaître un clavier
mais c'est un peu ça fait drôle non mais
ça va être comme ça va être commis
pardon c'est pour faire les mots non
mais pour dire tarawih pour dire les
réponses il est 21h fallait faire dodo
tout aussi choquée manque à cette
conditionne j'ai mis mon téléphone j'ai
mis le live sur mon téléphone pour
vérifier que tout marchait bien on voit
mon écran à moi avec du coup pas rentrer
à regarder le jeune regarde art et ma
soeur va nous rejoindre bientôt mais on
peut lancer toute façon pour rejoindre
votre moment 106 wii dont il faut des
points
oui oui voilà bonjour pas pour la gagne
si vous voulez mon jour nous rejoindre
je sais pas si tu as mis un lien dans le
ami de liens est ce que jamais le lien
direct comme ça oui on peut nu
il ya des gens qui arrivent et qui
lisent des insultes envers l'institution
bah du coup par contre il faut que
j'arrête le partage de seconde le temps
de faire ça j'ai peut être le lien cela
va être rigolo six mois du coup je le
mets à la place des bancs qui a alors je
mets dans le csab juste eh oui c'est ce
que j'allais lyrique élevé dans la
classe mais bien sûr on entend beaucoup
je remets le montant le chat youtube
directement parce que si tu le mets sur
le chateur stream
si tu le mets entre creux stream du coup
les gens vont pas pouvoir copier coller
le lien ouais mais attends je ne sais
pas je n'ai juste sur youtube et
normalement je ne sais pas si ça
fonctionne du coup mais j'aimais juste
pour lui et ceux qui sont pas sur
youtube venez sur youtube donne et on
est bien
trois personnes sur facebook et une
personne sur twitter on à christopher
bluff qui va nous rejoindre
ah oui sur you tube ça marche ya le lien
allez ça va être rigolo de simplicio
oui c'est ça qu'on soit au bureau c'est
un pictionnary et plus tueraient pour
vite plus tueraient pour i gotta points
et 6 mais du coup plus il ya de gens qui
trouvent moins ça fait deux points en
gros pour le
on s'en fout des et moi ça fait deux
points pour la personne et sachant que
quand c'est à toi tu dessines et à trois
options
donc tu peux choisir un peu quand même
qu'est ce que tu as qu'est ce que tu as
envie le plus de dessiner et il ya un
look et un timer avec des démos il te le
dise le nombre de mots le nombre de
lettres et plus le temps passe plus ça
rajoute de l'être pour faire ça donne
des indices en gros oui il faut
construire avec un pc ou l'écran il ya
le nombre de lettres ça c'est fait et tu
es on peut voir aussi les propositions
des autres gens et mais pas quand eux
enfin quand il donne des trucs qui se
rapproche trop de la réponse du coup ça
sa muse
quand on voit pas du coup la réponse
ouais voilà maintenant c'est ça va mais
un jour d'amour igolo bain et dan dah et
razak et lazarus qui nous on vous l'a
bien grand mot je pense mais vous livrer
sous le rejoindre aia devrait rejoindre
oui bonjour de grosse panne c'est un ami
voilà à quoi aurait pu le regarder je
lance le jeu
ok donc là il y avait une personne qui
choisit un mot c'est comme ça et oui du
coup si vous jouez jouez le jeu et ne
regardez pas l'écran de la preuve quand
c'est difficile parce que du coup ça
donne le sad maintenant les voilà au
quotidien est ce que si on en français
ou en anglais 1 100 français moi j'ai
trouvé les attend ah oui oui bah oui
allez qu'est ce qu'il ya
un jeu wii a besoin d'un français des
lions français après là pour le coup en
anglais ça marche aussi un communiqué
c'était pas l'animal qui comptait
n'hésitez pas c'est des gens qui nous
rejoignent qui ont encore des questions
sur time warp aussi on peut continuer de
parler en même temps bien sûr aller
viable a déclaré qu'un seul une fois
qu'on a prouvé je crois qu'on voit
traîneau oui c'est ça alors pourquoi
j'ai toujours alors
alors ok ok ça va être compliqué et je
me trouvais à non vous avez l'idée fait
annuler ce nom vous vivez du coup à
temps voilà comment j'ai maté j'ai raté
à temps pour vous merde attend chinois 1
mais non mais comment les filles bon
au blanc mais je sais bien qu'en tant
que tel war on attend il ya un truc tu
as avec le petit machin là ça voilà bon
là il avait un très beau moment garder
les 9 milliards
[Musique]
désolé c'est que très dur et woerth
c'était soit ça soit soudeur donc bon
c'est elliott que digg loué pour avoir
atteint l'objectif à merci et lieu voilà
moi je peux plus voir le chat switch
parce que du coup j'ai dû me mettre sur
youtube mais je joue moi aller que ce
qu'il y a j'adore ce jeu a donné des
majuscules je ne sers à rien qu'est ce
que c'est c'est vraiment une photo 1
c'est pour agir en erreur bon bah toi tu
sais de servir correctement des trucs
alors voilà à quoi allez vous avez des
trucs comme ça si le mot j'adore ça mais
je t'assure mon clavier habituel pour ça
que je passais moi j'ai la voix de ce
[Musique]
nom
ah oui on peut choisir la taille des
points céderait 2
[Musique]
j'ai ma soeur qui dit qu'elle est dans
le jeune et je la vois 1 à 6 et swing
nom et spring a dit non à un quoi les
couleurs sont importantes
qu'est ce qu'il ya non c'est quoi piquer
à orthographier je suis trop fier de moi
aulas tu te lances sur un terrain
glissant au swing à ses paroles oui dans
vrai danger en vrai c'était ferrari je
pense mais du coup j'ai cru comprendre
que swing c'est ma soeur oui c'est un
magnifique
il est beau un peu la thématique de
l'aéronef de tout à l'heure où à mieux
[ __ ] mais c'est trop bien faire bon
[Musique]
j'allais dire alcoolique haussier pour
du coup de hi hi hi eh ouais
ah oui oui bah oui attends je sais pas
les pneus avant non au report
[Musique]
le petit bonhomme le bonhomme nous a
arbois la attend ça normalement ça
devrait le faire allez les gars allez là
c'est une photo je peux pas je peux pas
faire mieux
[Rires]
je vois là attends je vais essayer de
mettre des couleurs mais il faut que je
me fous je bloque les plats attend qu'on
va mettre voilà marché attend là bas
c'est sur fond vert comme ça on peut là
on peut le détruire et noir va pouvoir
là mais papa et moi car notre dame
grossman telle une cour de france man ou
bong et quand je regarde sur l'un des
leurs les questions non ça a c'est moi
bah oui ça qu'à la première lettre
service qui piratent des ordinateurs
tabarand croyance populaire
nous avons un nouveau joueur
oui cette daube grossman c'est un amical
bonjour l'ami polar d'euros attend trois
mois à regarder les faut regarder les il
ya une indication swingers en eau par le
nombre de lettres comme un pendule
à temps mais je me sens qu'on en fait à
puce oui bah oui ça semble logique
j'étais dépassé le mur à je ne faisais
pas attention quand même à jet à aa
allez dernière mais non c'est pas
dernière a pu tinchant 3e puis tout ça
en fait je voulais surtout de
compétition mieux et les historiens sont
là bas un aspect qu'on va les axa mais
j'ai pas mal joué dans bellamy
il ya déjà eu une fois quand je jouais
où il y avait un mot qui était mal à mal
orthographié dans le jeu des coûts qu'à
ça oui car tôt et avait cathédrale à
plus tard à vous allez rester devant
d'ailleurs on peuvent être déposées
avant la descente n'est pas voilà gard
nîmes habile qu'est-ce que tu admires
ans quoi les maîtres français de faire
ça va vraiment non oui c'est pas s'y
attend essayez de faire je me permets
une pause pour dire que on est là pour
time warp aussi parce qu'un pack map
avoir fait ouvrir d'autres terroirs et
financer s'il ya des gens qui nous
rejoignent
on est à 5000 euros et si vous le voulez
vous pouvez toujours continuer de
partager la campagne est de donner de
l'argent pourquoi pas quelque chose de
bien récupérer supérieur d'atteindre le
même rythme de finances pour que pour la
saison et ça nous permettait de
rémunérer un peu chacun des membres de
l'équipe qui pour l'instant sont
bénévoles et donc ce serait fort bien
pouvoir voilà oui et
la saison de la thune payer cet été on
est content mais comme tu fais je sais
pas bah si mais du coup à oui non peut
la nommer bien joué court 1 alors voilà
la moustache très haut à ckoi ça à temps
mais tu as
oh oh ouais bah non merci je suis quand
même mes amis oui mais oui oui nous
retrouver avec toujours en toile
avez vous commencé à creuser votre
invention
ça s'annonce compliqué ok ils partirent
dans quelque chose de conception
technique
voilà
[Musique]
mais au moins il est heureux n'a pas
grand chose pour viale ces petits biceps
là non je veux pas c'est important
apparemment qui soirs où ça important
[Rires]
vient vers le rwanda
ottawa la sapmer je pense bien une loi
et non une dernière une maintenant qu'on
a du monde robinson le lien est le lien
est toujours et toujours aux multiples
déceptions avec la troupe où vous pouvez
nous rejoindre si vous voulez dire si
vous les aimez ça sera la dernière je
pense après on vraiment j'avais moins en
plus leurs mots assez durs
[Musique]
qu'est ce que demande
ah oui avant afin selon écrire ici moi
j'ai pas de clavier déjà que oui c'est
le diable et espaces et tout mais c'est
petit et haïti tahiti a dans nos maisons
il était très figuratif pas comment
c'était du minimalisme bah oui je
m'impose en l'air quand même pour les
chaussures à un recul de 1 des villes à
[ __ ] un ennemi
on va faire tout le vocabulaire de la
cordonnerie donc plus rien à voir
d'ailleurs bien joué c'est tout bloquer
[Musique]
un long j'ai trouvé un peu ça allait
s'arrêter dans les jambes bien lourdes
jetant un dernier nom a cédé petit
string
parce que oui les plus est un acteur non
tu as quand même le service un peu wen e
place de vinci way home étape de la
petite poule du milieu ah oui ouais
c'est vrai c'est que tu dois
avec la la ça trouve ça trop hein ça ah
mais oui oh oui
ah j'ai été informé correctement ses sa
a appris ça à moi olala attend non mais
c'est trop dur là à temps pour choisir
difficulté j'aime j'aime les risques à
temps ouais exactement pourquoi je peux
pas écrire pourquoi ça écrit pas et
n'eut pas attention à ici voilà j'étais
sur un album à part contre ouais voilà
maintenant essayer de faire et de tarifs
bon voilà un
de beauté bah c'est un peu c'est un peu
cursed 1 vous avez l'idée quoi mais
c'est quoi point d'achoppement la fois
vergeladi dessous quelqu'un sait dominer
mais rotative jet d'encre uv en veulent
à tout jamais être moment c'était belle
et qu'il s'agisse bel air à la ferme
c'est parce que c'est sincère
l'essentiel est bon oui bah oui mais bon
alors oui quoi sa tête est coupée parce
que c'est pas ça qui est important
ouh là oh là là non
comment vous avez pu trouver cette
personne là bas et ça à cette galère
bah oui oui ça ne va pas du tout simple
la maison voilà voilà des fois c'est
compliqué c'est plus jaune
à un genre qu'on salue dédicace à tous
les parisiens qui nous regardent
toujours un quoi bonsoir
j'hésite entre deux il faut choisir
ok au ballon mais j'étais sûr de moi en
plus violents à la schola et là j'ai
fait et j'ai fait un très bon mais vous
avez tous trouvé ces mois là on est
d'accord
oui je suis mais je savais que c'était
faux mais j'ai fait quand même à vous
avez trouvé
oui mais comment du coup c'est pas ça ça
nous tient
non ah oui si j'ai jamais ce soir des
fois je terreur j'allais le pas facile
finalement un ya tellement de trucs qui
ressemble que du cours est passé
non mais tu avais bien dit à l'aise
petite indication souvent la galette
naître maintenant [ __ ] le relais et
[Musique]
moi je perds du temps à chaque fois vous
faut que je mette le la phil l'écran qui
savent pas le clavier s'afficher plus en
plus du coup quand le clavier sa fille
j'ai pu le dessin en entier ni les
lettres
c'est tout un bazar style super 5
secondes
[Applaudissements]
je vais je n'abandonne pas beaucoup de
lettres un géographe
mais non c'est pas ça
c'est une wii est très belle et jamais
un fou je sais pas du tout j'ai pas le
je pense que je connais pas le mot tu
sais je prends du mieux à même à paris
effectivement mais j'habite à côté
oui parce que tu ne m a pas de technique
c'est un petit âgées voient à huy et jay
[Musique]
haas a fait - les mains
batla mourut à je n'ai pas compris
j'avais par go par mois quand même entre
lazaro c'est moi à 2-1
bah voilà mais oui à la couche est en
jeu n'est pas resté là je vais en
choisira qui est très actuel et fincke
et très dans le thème de ce soir
maintenant est-ce que je vais réussir à
le dessiner ep
rocco qui nous dit bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue pour parler de time warp
mais on est parti maintenant petit voilà
c'est vraiment je pense qu'on est
utilisé dans la websérie un short et
offre donc non je dis pour la personne
qui vient de nous rejoindre
on a atteint le premier panier on va
pouvoir trouver la saison de taille noir
donc si tu as raté le début tu peux
revoir
on a beaucoup parlé de la série de nos
projets on a ce pôle est un petit peu
sûr de quoi parlera la saison 2 et là on
termine sur sur des petits jeux quoi et
tu peut même venir jouer trsb lorsqu'on
est donc de leur indiquer où je pense
qu'on a bientôt fini mais tu peux nous
mais ouais je pense que c'est la fin de
la partie quand même bientôt là au
[ __ ] vous êtes vous si long
[Musique]
ah j'ai normalement à ta [ __ ] et puis
c'est quoi ces eaux-là la décision
d'athènes de shakespeare du coup je
pense d'ailleurs au mahdi donc ouais tu
sais induit en erreur en vrai à temps là
donc c'est pas ça non mais quand même ah
bah oui à quoi je pensais je dis pas non
contre bath est trop long ça peut pas
être une contrebasse ouais mais là bas
sont vrais a dessiné c'est compliqué un
bond de 2 me
ah ok et le retour du bonhomme bâton ne
prenons pas la peine est là mais pas
trop à
ah [ __ ] nous étaient conviés les
autres c'est plus ce que c'était
selon cet élu j'avais boîte de nuit
comme autres vaut quelque chose qu'on ne
connaît plus beaucoup j'ai tapé un
membre est ce que c'est que ce truc là
on est au troisième vendée après on va
arrêter donc je pense que ça va plus
trop court rejoindre
je réponds à une question vient par
contre la gelée plus il est prêt ou dans
les commandes et pas très loin au dessus
dans les commentaires peut toujours
rejoindre
je garantis pas que ça sera pour
longtemps à
attends c'est quoi ça ah oui non non non
le premier mot que j'ai tapé il m'a dit
vous êtes proche ce qui est je le vois
c'est vrai qu'en bêta c'est tout à fait
pour agen moi je suis en salopette la
dernière ford était le chapeau du thème
salopette à cheikh guèye a une astuce ne
sais pas il m'a pas pris le mien oui non
oui parce qu'ils veulent être en trop du
coup ça m'a induit en erreur parce que
je pensais que c'était place amende de
ce truc c'est que j'avais mis un accent
il fallait pas aller dans j'aime bien
les rangs trois oui j parce que
contrairement aux croyances une et que 2
voilà j'ai perdu sur sa super pas grave
je mène mais on a du bon
ça c'est fait ouais il est un peu relou
des fois sur des trucs et pas l'accent
dasté set que j'ai mis 3 attend quoi
balou ouais je sais attendez si c'est
pas bien vieille 1 à huawei
alors allez on a bien su choisir une
bonne petite difficulté là au plat donc
critique non voilà ou à la couleur four
typique des critiques
justement à écrire c'est pas juste
voilà pour moi y rajouter des petits
détails comme disent nos jeunes qui
parmi nous aujourd'hui on faisait des
bons jours des tu arrives dans la fin
mais on en voit donc on n'en voudra pas
si tu te retrouves dernier faisait pas
attention auxerre des premiers
malheureusement la prof est trop loin
devant ça s'annonce compliqué la
défiance de la ba [ __ ]
[Musique]
après ta je fais des fautes
ouais je voulais faire ma recette sous
cahiers du personnage
les personnages à voile à ses petites
fesses oui il est drôle franchement tu
aurais tu t'en sors bien tu t'en sors
vais inscrire n'est pas simple mais rien
est à moi oh là là attention
est ce que est ce que justin va
reprendre sa place et pourquoi je mets
insurrection oui françois tu as dépassé
bonsoir répondrai pas
mais du coup j'ai pas les moyens qu'ils
savent être mieux c'est pas parce que
deux amoureux de ces tel plan depuis le
début au bâton là
[Rires]
olam est incroyable voila voila c'est
quoi s'est débrouillé comme un bon ami à
moi qui trouve alors je considère que
ces mots je voulais voir effectivement
aulas oui le gestionnaire eu là un bravo
non non on a bien rigolé on a fait fuir
tout le monde je pense
on est onze on est toujours me voilà
enfin on était un petit peu plus avant
mais on est toujours resté onze c'était
sympa j'espère que ça vous a plu
inouï nous ça nous a plu c'est déjà pas
mal
et en 125 on peut peut-être faire un
petit mot sur tes marques pour terminer
et oui bien joué trop forte oui c'est
vrai
à tous les gens qui nous on regarde
c'est vraiment sympa surtout j'avais
jamais trophée de live avant cette
campagne time warp rendrait la prochaine
fois tu pourras m que sur youtube
je pense oui son soutien le plus de gens
à chaque fois il ya quelques jours sur
facebook en mai mais la yamaha 2 surtout
oui parce qu'en vrai du coup avec
l'interaction avec les autres fait que
c'est bien lui tient pas pour tout le
monde que d'après en passant par
resterez mais ça coûte rien ouais ça
coûte rien de deux mètres sur les autres
réseaux quoi même en termes de quoi et
dont je suis pas en termes de bande
passante
oui dans sa / ça doit peut-être compter
un petit peu plus mais là en étant près
de la borne sur un ordi puissant ça va
aider à la fois le truc c'est que
c'était sur mon ordi qui est beaucoup
moins puissant on écrit avec un jeu en
plus qui tournait et et plus bas du coup
c'était le jeu plus stream laddh
tout ça ça ça à consommer beaucoup plus
c'est pour ça que la vidéo du dernier
live où on a joué à m'engager pas mis
sur youtube parce que ça va j'ai regardé
ma belle victoire c'est tellement déçu
mais oui c'était très sympa je sais pas
si on fait un live finale le dernier son
copain encore avec tout le monde que ce
soit bien seab là puisque tous deux
partis à paarl parleurs en même temps
ouais mais c'est passionnant mais on
verra ça aussi pour tenir les gens au
courant de nos avancement à tout ça de
nos répétitions complètement
mais si on peux plus je pense que c'est
le signe qu'il faut arrêter mais du coup
encore merci pour vos dons et et vous
pouvez regarder si vous avez pris ce
live en cours de route vous pouvez
regarder le début où on parle beaucoup
de time warp et où on a expliqué à quoi
servirait de budget où on en est et
canton quand est-ce qu'on tournera aussi
est aussi quoi pour faire dans la saison
2 à quoi servira le budget si on
continue d'avoir des dons parce qu'on
peut toujours n'hésitez pas toujours à
partager parce que tout argent
supplémentaire nous sera utile nous
permettra de tourner dans des conditions
de mieux en mieux d'être deuxième assist
au real pour justement pouvoir aider à
décharger aussi faire tout ça ça ça peut
être bien et ça peut nous aider à faire
quelque chose le mieux possible et 22h
ça y est la femme dans tous les sens et
du coup voilà vous pouvez aussi revoir
les deux précédents live qui se trouve
sur youtube et il continue de partager
le lien et même si jamais il n'y a plus
de live tous les jours je continue de
poster les choses de mettre des
newsletters
je vais faire une nouvelle muse demain
ou après demain je ne sais plus où je
parlerai des nouveaux personnages sans
ce pôle est encore une fois mais un peu
comme ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui par
écrit pour les gens qui n'étaient pas là
et je ferai une dernière view news aussi
avant la fin de la campagne pour parler
du budget ou dans des salles aussi et
voilà qui dans un moment de la fin merci
à tous c'était rigolo on a bien rigolé
c'était cool de regarder le mignan n'a
pas bien fait de deux mètres le bêtisier
1 c'était sympa oui si vous avez manqué
le début on a aussi regardé le bêtisier
de la saison une cloud pourrait
retrouver sur youtube
mais si en plus vous voulez nos
commentaires par dessus la vous
m le début de celle là et vous aurez le
bêtisier oui mais on est content parce
qu'en plus on a aussi continué d'avoir
des dons on a eu encore 125 auront ce
soir donc merci beaucoup aussi encore
mercier à la personne qui a repris la
lettre là les avec des enluminures qui
propose des trucs avant que c'est même
pas elle qui va s'en occuper de ses
magasins 8h et ans et si vous faites un
bon vous pouvez demander si vous faites
un bond de 60 euros vous choisissiez la
bête n'hésitez pas à demander la lettre
de lucrecia et kenny se fera une joie de
vous écrire à la ba de faire plein de
choses mais bien sûr ça sera manuscrits
[Musique]
sap et cela à balai ou fait les choses
bien et moi je veux qu acheter les
miennes évidemment pas toi tu t'es
lucrecia jeu je vais te dire que de les
graver dans la hanche
oui mais moi j'ai des trucs du cirque
chinois contemporain jan valach
décidemment la voilà vous aurez deux
cachets différents 1-2 aliénor ben voilà
on a contrepartie qui est celle à 2,60
euros et qui est limité et vous aurez
des lettres il reste quatre lettres de
ningbo et cette lettre de lucrecia moi
aussi j'ai des cachets pour les jeux de
rôles ça fait bien mes jeux de rôle en
effet en ligne en ce moment c'est bien
aussi
on y va on voir tout le monde et puis un
oui on va vous laisser
et merci beaucoup et bonne soirée bon
week end bonne continuation et merci
beaucoup pour taiwan ou et aussi de la
part de tous les gens qui pouvaient pas
être là ce soir mais qui sont dans
l'équipe
merci de leur part vous savez
partis dormir et je vais